how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and all things relating to the
MCU and a happy fourth of July to
everybody who is celebrating today today
we have a special July 4th MCU scoop
coming from Mikey Sutton this is an
exclusive scoop that it gave it to me so
thank you for that Mikey and what we're
talking about today is Miles Morales in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
possibly being called ultimate
spider-man so we'll break it all down in
this video but first if you're new be
sure to subscribe I cover everything
relating to Marvel including trailers
reports rumors everything also this
week's giveaway is a black panther Funko
pop all you got to do to enter is
subscribe like the video and leave a
comment about the video down below so
here's the report from Mikey Sutton
spider-man is dead and a blockbuster
scoop from months ago
Mikey Sutton revealed that current plans
were to bring back Tobey Maguire for one
last swing as the amazing arachnid for a
live-action interpretation of into the
spider verse which would find him
teaming up with Tom Holland and Andrew
Garfield this is something that I
reported exclusively on my channel
however there was a bit of a catch it
wouldn't have a happy ending as they
would like to have Maguire and quite
possibly original spider-man director
Sam Raimi died at the climax in heroic
in-game fashion this would inspire Miles
Morales to become spider-man in that
universe but the incredible popularity
of Miles Morales is too massive now to
be satisfied by animated fare but
according to my keys inside sources
there are talks to have a separate
franchise of a Miles Morales lead
live-action spider-man movies possibly
called ultimate spider-man to separate
them from Tom Hollands hugely popular
franchise the initial discussions are
being held right now for the first
Morales picture to take place years
after the conclusion of spider-verse or
whatever it will be called this will be
about Miles Morales in his infancy stage
of being a superhero learning the ropes
as a costumed crime fighter but also as
a boy becoming a man and falling in love
you see miles is about to land a
girlfriend and she isn't an ordinary
teenager either miles will be paired
with
spider-gwen in a contemporary twist on
the original Silver Age story arc as
with miles a story spider-gwen already
exists there is no long origin story
right now the reports say that Sony will
be releasing this movie but apparently
Kevin Feige is seriously interested in
producing this himself another extension
of Disney's relationship with Sony miles
morales won't replace tom holland but
instead this series will exist with his
the question remains though if Kevin
Feige is involved will Miles Morales
exist in the MCU and here's where the
multiverse will kick in miles will make
references to Tom Hollands spider-man
and either through magical or scientific
means collaborate with him again or even
meet some of the Avengers which is
something that would be absolutely
incredible and something that we would
all love to see discussions have started
right now there's nothing officially
confirmed yet but Sony wants a Miles
Morales franchise and it seems like
Marvel Studios wants in on it as well
which of course just makes perfect sense
after the success of spider-man into the
spider-verse
and the success that Tom Hollands
spider-man has had in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and especially
creating an entire universe with Sony
revolving around spider-man with venom
Morbius and other films to come as well
and not to mention it seems very clear
that Miles Morales is a priority for
Marvel Studios and Sony right now
they both recently announced the video
game spider-man Miles Morales an entire
game based around miles of story with
him of course being the main character
so clearly since Sony and Marvel made an
entire video game based off of miles
they're definitely thinking about him
right now and also given the fact that
Kevin Feige right now is all about
diversity it would make perfect sense
for them to bring miles into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and with the
multiverse coming into play in phase 4
it's the perfect opportunity to bring
him into the MCU or even have him in the
Sony universe but have him connect to
the MCU just like Morbius will he can
reference Tom Hollands spider-man but
can't reference any other events that
take place in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but Tom Holland can cross over
into his movies but hopefully there will
be a deal worked out that lets Miles
Morales enter the actual Marvel
Cinematic Universe and according to this
report with him will come spider-gwen
so let me know how excited you would be
for a Miles Morales franchise to start
with spider-gwen leave all your thoughts
down below and don't forget to like this
video and subscribe to stay up to date
on all things relating to the MCU if you
want live updates you can follow me on
Twitter I hope everybody has a great 4th
of July if you're celebrating today and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof